right good morning everybody and welcome
to this Extra Ordinary cabinet meeting
in preparation for Council later today
we are looking a bit thin on the ground
I've had apologies from councillor
Richards as being unwell but I've had a
message from Pemberton assuring me he'd
be here by 11:00 and nobody knows where
my brains got to but so have I upstaged
you there mr. sheepy and done apologies
for absence apologize for right
disclosures of interests not right items
three local development scheme this
papers come to us because periodically
we are required to produce a timetable
at that time table is for the work being
done to develop a planning policy in
particularly round the local development
framework the core strategy is the BOK
of the local development framework and
that has to be compliant with the MPP F
national policy and other national
policies and you know that was approved
in July last year as we well know there
are some other issues still to be dealt
with the local plan for example
requested some master plans okay and
those master plan works are still
underway we also have to do a gypsy and
traveler policy although fortunately we
don't have pressure on us at the present
time from gypsy and traveler sites
we're also compiling supplementary
planning guidance for the canal quarter
again these were issues that had to be
done in the wake of the core strategy
adoption
and as such they're all in appendix
something or other one which contains a
timetable and what I'm basically asking
you today is to ask Council this
afternoon to approve that timetable the
site allocations plan is for additional
sites we were asked to produce
additional sites again in the core
strategy this wasn't work that could
have been done earlier it's work that
has to be done in the wake of the
adoption of the core strategy and I'm
not particularly pleased to report but
with issues around in this work which
has been ongoing we are looking to
actually finally adopt that by july 2019
the [ __ ] and Traveller plan at the same
time the canal quarter SPD later
although that would be desirable to
bring forward no it's not later it's
July 2018
and the development requirements SPD
will come in at a similar time so we are
batching the work together the
development requirements is
supplementary planning guidance on
things like car parking etc and then
finally we've got the community
infrastructure levy I am going to bring
a paper to cabinet on the 30th of
November if that's the right date and
that will go on to Council on the 11th
of December to adopt the community
infrastructure levy we had been waiting
for a long time since the EIP for the
inspectors report that inspectors report
is now in but he didn't come in soon
enough for us to have matter and reports
prepared and tactics agreed to actually
deal with today so I have spoken to
mr. week so sadly not with us oh he's on
holidays there yes mr. weeks about it
and he is now notifying applicants that
there could well be a change of policy
approved by council on the 11th of
December we could implement it that day
we could implement it later and that's
one of the decisions we've yet to make
and it's probably desirable that a small
amount of lead in time is necessary but
based on those dates mr. Wiggs is now
informing planning applicants that the
policy could well change and what it
means is they'll be far fewer s106
agreements except of course on
affordable housing there will not be
infrastructure movements on transport in
infrastructure etc so consequently that
is where we are so we have that as
scheduled that is a change and it
doesn't show the changes but on the
other hand I have discussed this with
mr. kair foot who's here if we need him
to answer questions and indeed I think
this is probably a reasonable timetable
we have had one or two issues with
staffing being light in the policy team
but those are largely been remedied now
and I think we can say that's going to
be a team that's going to be fit and
able to deal with this timetable so any
questions then on the local development
scheme that's a fancy name for a
timetable councillor moss Thank You
chairman
no it's not the cure for some shortages
and the previous paragraph says it is
now proposed to revert to two
consultations so one must presume that
we are streamlining the process and two
consultations should be enough the work
as you will know is done through a small
group called L pack leaders policy
Advisory Group and effectively they're
looking at things and we do change the
officer recommendations in that group
and but I think that the the two
consultations it's been boys being
proposed people could modify it it's
being proposed that we have that we have
adequate public exposure within those
two consultations
three years late no I'm not personally
happy with how long this has taken but
if you recall councillor Morse mr. drew
who was the examiner on the court
strategy did decide that we could and
should take the main elements of the
course G first without the gypsy and
trap on a plan if I can just finish
please right because that does help
answer your question we have had extreme
difficulty in identifying sites and we
can't play that down you might like to
think that the administration is
incompetent but I'm not putting those
words into your mouth this afternoon or
even this morning the issue is that most
people who are wanting development will
want a better return of their land that
they can get for a gypsy site and we
have looked at the issues over public
land and county council land and there's
been considerable difficulty in reaching
agreement and we've had to consider
looking at compulsory purchase that work
has not proceeded rapidly I will concede
but on the other hand it is something
that we're going to do and plan to do
within this new timetable okay right
hello Darren right you haven't found
count now I got your note saying you're
gonna come at 11 o'clock sharp but 5
past is quite good for you you haven't
found counselor brain and wandering
around by the way have you loitering
because he's missing 2 right anyway but
anyway you're in time for the first
decision so we're making a
recommendation to Council that the local
plan documents be prepared according to
a timetable and that we bring that
timetable into effect as our official
timetable for the outstanding work on
planning policy to complement the core
strategy is that agreed great thank you
by moving on to item 4 strategic review
final report now this is here because
the strategic review group was set up as
a group that comprised some cabinet
members and some other members of the
council and we've had one or two issues
over membership or one or two challenges
but we've retained that membership from
the start all the way through I had
promised council that they would have a
site of a final report by today and
indeed a decision from us this morning
will present this report to fall Council
this afternoon it's been a very thorough
piece of work it was done in three
stages the first stage was to look at
some of the the nuts and bolts of issues
and discuss those with stakeholders and
indeed I'm making certain that members
of the public become aware that we have
really engaged with stakeholders quite
well and this did us a lot of good in
our peer review report that we underwent
earlier in the year so consequently
we've done that we've identified a lot
of financials
and there here is a set of proposals not
to make a decision about today but to
decide they are the right way forward
for decisions that will evolve in the
coming months so as a consequence we had
four working groups we'll have five
working groups but one of the working
groups was effectively the entire
strategic review group of eight
counselors we had four working groups
one that looked at our benchmarking
another looked at new ways of working
another that looked at opportunities for
generating income and a fourth one which
looked at a bit of a mop-up of anything
else we hadn't thought of in the first
three groups but those groups
effectively have had their proposals
compiled into the report we have today
and you'll see the work streams are
numbered
while the reports are on work streams
two three four and five because they're
the ones that did the work and they
summarized the opportunities for reform
realistically we've got to look up
reducing our officer footprint in the
building and lease out more of this
building we've already done that to one
degree I mean we've had a an area on the
ground floor of this council building
that as first was leased out to the
Royal Shakespeare Company when they were
rebuilding the theaters it was then
taken on by Warren County Council who
decided to desert us and we now have a
private contractor fully engaged with
that work and that private contractor
will take over the ground floor we look
like do to some work that's been done by
mr. perks being able to reduce the
footprint of occupancy of this building
far further and I shall be encouraging
the council
take every opportunity to do that
it means removing some of the piles of
paper that exists around the office and
I can't be too proud about that because
my office is full of them but the issue
is that we're going to have to have some
IT upgrades and smartening up in order
to achieve this and there will be a cost
to that though mr. Platts assures me the
cost will not be vast
he will bring all the skill to play in
order to remodel what we do and as a
consequence of that we will have perhaps
a more mobile workforce in many respects
but home working as we know it today
will be a thing of the past because if
officers are allowed to reduce the
footprint from here by home working they
will be expected to be in contact with
everybody whilst they're home working
which we know isn't always the case at
the present time but also by having less
paperwork in the office we can perhaps
deal with smaller desks than the ones
that we've been using which on my
recollection were bought about 15 years
ago so consequently that is where we are
that's a brief summary that's a very
brief summary of where we are and it's
essentially what I haven't I have missed
out in my introduction which I ought to
mention is joint working because we're
often criticised in our joint working
proposals but we found some benefit for
joint working with different councils on
different projects you know business
rates we deal with Warwick District
Council right car parking we deal with
which Haven District Council and so on
and so forth we even still do some work
on hospital which er well but when we
tried to put all our
in that basket situations didn't have a
happy outcome so consequently there are
ways of dealing with it and there is a
national agenda on this as well that
effectively will look that smart working
are probably amongst clusters of
districts but we'll see how it goes
however they're all decisions for the
future what the strategic review group
is identified the problems that matter
now clearly if councillors think there's
some gaps in there and they must raise
those this afternoon but on the other
hand the members of the group will be
there and I hope that they will agree
but the effectively this is a realistic
assessment of where we're going and in
the future we will use that to govern
our budget and our costs but we will
also look but smarter ways of working
and will always look because we've had a
very good report from the peer review
that we started it we will take very
seriously our work with our business
partners the ones that contribute an
awful lot of income to this council so
sorry that was slightly longer than I
planned
but you patiently listen to me any
questions on the report councillor Morse
you are a member of the society review
group so I'll assume that you've bought
into this report because keeping these
things up to date is very difficult
because of the advanced timing
got to give us all the papers but I just
thought that make two observations one
is that on page 18 the reserves were no
forecasting at year-end 17 18 are
significantly higher than the figures
shown yeah and of course on page 21 when
we look at the for strategic projects
tracks the note on priori Square three
generations in sturdily is not entirely
up to date right I mentioned primary
squared sadly first I'm very
disappointed that the early period we've
drawn out funding they did so without
any notice to this council they met
quietly and said no more
there was a reason but I do think that
some dialogue with with officers or even
members of this council would have been
beneficial before they just said we are
withdrawing funding because that's
precisely what they did last Monday
morning it's as recent as that now quite
clearly this paper had been published
for this meeting today so you're right
we have got a moving feast
however if council riches wasn't on his
sickbed this morning I'm fairly
certainly be in a position to tell us
that there are other projects in Studley
there are two other projects in Studley
that we have however that doesn't
address the question of this site as an
eyesore but I know there are questions
going to be answered asked this
afternoon and no doubt there will be
issues where we look into this we've
been trying hard to improve our
relationships with the early Paree which
aren't good I will coming months and
this is a bit of a setback but on the
other hand okay it does mark effective
things changed we as a council though
have not turned our back on the the
oddly regeneration project
and there may well be other options
other than the one you put your question
in for this afternoon that it could be
that we adopt who knows we will
effectively work extremely positively
but I personally gave commitments to the
local ward member as saturda back and
also to members of the public that have
come to Council and asked me questions
and I feel particularly let down
technically the goal posts have moved
which justified the early appease
position but they needn't have rushed at
it because any alternative ownership of
that site has got some way to go before
it actually comes to fruition and a
reality thank you Jim I appreciate you
taking the og question this afternoon
accounts all that is appreciated you've
mentioned several things that we're not
familiar with it it may be best to leave
it to see your answer this afternoon
okay any other comment then about the
strategic review group councillor house
just one small point mr. chairman page
30 item 6.3 a timeline will be developed
to underpin this approach do we have any
idea when that timeline might be
produced hang on page page 30
item 6.3
at the bottom
right
can someone who was on that work stream
helping out here basically we've got the
Sookie Tohono sat there he's the head of
head of infrastructure and
transformation and he will be
responsible for a lot of these projects
in terms of delivery working councilor
riches thank you check out the way that
I read this and because I I'm on board
with the establishing the timeline that
makes great sense and we can at least
manage that
but what cabinet are doing today is
agree in the next steps at which point
the experts will then start to put
together a timeline that I'm sure will
be appropriate so I'm not sure whether
or not we could be expected to give that
timeline right away because we're going
to agree those next steps now but no I
would be my thinking of it I appreciate
that the timeline can't be produced what
I was asking is do we have any idea when
that timeline will be published so we
can't see it excuse me and my hope is by
the end of this month we will have
addictive timeline again I need to speak
with the key stakeholders
should be 3.4 okay hopefully counts the
house you've had an answer now so good
thank you any other query or or issue
fine now I'm told there's a misprint in
the recommendations here the proposed
vision for the council which nobody's
mentioned which has been organized by a
committee is not in paragraph three
point five and I'm fumbling papers here
three point four okay
so the recommendations are the proposed
vision for the council identify 3.5 is
approved it'll be up to Council to
approve that but we are going to
recommend that version and it did go
around the block a bit and several
people contributed to that strategy for
stakeholder engagement is approved and
the findings of individual work streams
be received and provide guidance for the
council's policy and budget framework
and the proposed delivery mechanism for
which we've had a answer just now in
Section six be approved now I'll propose
take as it's a recommendation to Council
to take all four recommendations
together whether the chairman of the
council does that this afternoon is up
to him so if there's no further comment
I'll ask for your endorsement to those
recommendations as modified go to
Council this afternoon is that agreed
agreed
thank you right the next item is a late
paper of which I haven't bought one with
me ah thank you
has everybody got a copy of the business
rate retention this is a government
scheme thank you John yeah this is a
government scheme if you remember there
was a proposal at the Conservative Party
conference in 2016 by the then
Chancellor Exchequer to actually agree a
timetable for a hundred percent business
rates retention by district councils but
being we didn't keep and spend it all I
have one member who's no longer
remember that actually wrote survey with
huge plans for spending the lot
unfortunately we have to share it out
and share quite a bit with the County
Council because the county council don't
collect business rates we do so we
collect their share as well as
everything else so as a consequence
there will be a formula to carving it up
and also we would have to send some of
our business race off to other councils
that are not deemed to be as well-off as
we are that was put into draft
legislation earlier this year and then
we had a general election and it was not
picked up in the Queen's speech leaders
and other representatives of district
councils that forums I attended
nationally cried foul we made a lot of
noise about it and now what's happened
is that we've had this proposal come
forward for a pilot not everybody will
get accepted for the pilot but what mr.
Buckland has done is he's had
discussions with the other authorities
in Warwickshire about the feasibility of
creating a business rate pilot according
to the rules and that would need to
involve the County Council and the other
authorities in Warwickshire there are
financial advantages for doing that
compared to being on our own because if
we're on our own don't forget we're
still in the regime instigated by mr.
pickels some years ago whereby we
collected all the business rates but 50%
of it went to the government they've got
themselves in some tight corners over
this because under the 1990s legislation
it all had to be spent within local
government so consequently CLG then
thought of all sorts of ways of giving
it back to author
is in different formats however the
rules are changing and rate Support
Grant is going to disappear in fact I
think some authorities appear to be
going to a situation where they have
negative rate support grant quite how
that's going to be banished I'm not
going to ask mr. Buckland to explain
this afternoon but whatever the case we
have a situation where business rates or
we have an opportunity to take part in a
business rate pool and again the
recommendations which I think are a
decision that cabinet can make are they
not we don't have to refer this one to
Council now right the finances involved
are explained in the report and council
organ and councillor riches and our
selves all had a briefing about this
last week and therefore we are
recommending that we do apply to be part
of the wider Warwickshire business rate
pool if that is so granted questions to
mr. Buckland plays sorry oh yes
counselor boss
Jaguar Land Rover and Aston Martin and I
think are in many ways formidable if
brexit goes badly wrong so we would pick
up a hit I take it if the child was
there so I would support this but I
think we do need to do so always open
but my main point was that I understand
it if we are accepted that's clearly up
to the government we will recover four
hundred and seventy five thousand pounds
as a safety net from the existing pool
and we will get five hundred and thirty
eight thousand for sustainability of
services and I take it that million
pounds will be effectively added to our
reserves at the year end yes making them
even more and when we get community
infrastructure levy they'll be even more
in the reserves as well
however yes so I mean Chris emulation
absolutely right so the four hundred
seventy five thousand is the reserve
that we've generated it's being held by
the County Council that will be payable
to us if we're successful if we're not
successful that that will stay with the
county council and the existing pool
will continue the community
infrastructure levels we can't use for
our general fund reserves we can make
bids along with other parties for
funding but it won't be part of our
general fund reserves I accept that but
I did say that tongue-in-cheek well
however I agree that whatever we hold in
community infrastructure levy will need
to be deployed in infrastructure
projects of one sort or another but
they'll inevitably be a time when we're
banking it council Jefferson given the
increasing risk will the requirement for
minimum reserves increase person I'm not
suggesting at the moment what we are
doing is slightly increasing the
volatility fund so in the first year
we'll be creating effectively a new
reserve at five hundred thirty eight
thousand that will be held by the county
as I said the four hundred and seventy
will be paid back to us the risk that we
are increasing yes at the moment were
effectively responsible for four
percent of the risk on collection
because we the business rate is split
between the local share in the central
share on the local share we get 80% of
that risk so that's effectively 40% of
quantum this is opening this up to 50
percent of the quantum so the risk is a
further 10 percent in in the event that
there is a significant downturn and
that's reflected in the value of ability
to reserve been at 475 outside 538 not
475 so that should be sufficient to
cover that risk right any more queries
or questions on this right well the
proposal is and I apologize that you had
the paper very late but that's all to do
with the timing if we didn't consider it
today we'd have a job making in the
application because of the deadline has
been set by government and I think have
we consulted we counselor how's about so
the the item wasn't shown with the
default plan and therefore we notified
the chair the OSC that it would be
coming today it's not effectively
emergent paper it was it didn't make the
agenda but it was notified in time for
the agenda so this could still be
calling attention no something to
counsel it potentially could be coping
yes right would that affect our ability
to apply by the deadline I think it
unlike the calling would actually be
heard before the deadline so I guess we
wouldn't make their submission and then
we would have to revise our position if
we were if I would see then decided that
we shouldn't well of course they can't
overall a cabinet decision they can ask
you to take the decision again okay
well to degree we've been given a very
tight deadline but anyway
right we have still got to do some work
under the current business rates pool we
have a memorandum understanding which is
how we behave towards each other as
separate councils within the ball which
of course gave rise to the reserve mr.
Buckland referred to and that work has
still got to be done okay we have a
deadline to the response of the 27th of
October so if we publish decisions today
mr. sheep here or tomorrow whatever is
possible I wouldn't like to hassle you
or put you under pressure
the deadline for call in will be
Wednesday next week which is kind of
fairly close to the 27th of October so
we'll have to manage that situation but
in saying all that I'm just being
cautious I would hope the members of the
council would support this decision if
we make it and actually we go ahead and
take the financial advantages there are
from being part of a pool so the record
so you're very clear this is only for
2018-19 as well this is a learning
exercise that government will then
reflect upon the results of the pilots
for 1920 onwards well they might make
decisions about the future the problem
is to really change it to what George
Osborne had in mind would require
primary legislation and we know that
isn't bland so we're just going to have
to watch this place Chloe closely
because there we go right
on page 1 of the supplementary papers we
have recommendations one that we accept
the invitation to be pilot on 100%
business rate retention I think that
should be a pilot not be pilot right now
we are going to be a pilot we hope is
that agreed agree and then right subject
to that the executive director s15 was
authorized in consultation with the
leader to agree the proposed memorandum
of understanding before we agree that I
will share that with members so is that
agreed agreed agreed thank you
right no urgent business then mr. Webb
not chairman I can declare this meeting
of the cabinet closed